[Musique étrangère]
saviez-vous que certaines créatures sur
Terre sont en fait immortelles,
un exemple est un type de minuscule méduse
qui est capable d'affecter le développement
de ses cellules si elle est malade,
endommagée ou vieille,
elle se rétracte dans son
polype  mettre en scène et réapparaître
imaginez si les humains pouvaient apprendre à
régénérer notre corps à un âge plus jeune
imaginez réapparaître dans
des milliers d'années
[Musique]
donc c'est une de nos ambulances à
demain biostase demain par stase
une de mes organisations c'est essentiellement une
entreprise de préservation des foules ou
Organisation pour l'Europe, elle travaille
en collaboration avec des fondations à but non lucratif en
Suisse et l'idée est que
chaque fois qu'un de nos membres décède,
avec une de ces ambulances et
l'équipe médicale à l'intérieur
et l'équipement, nous pouvons pleurer ou
les préserver.  C'est fondamentalement l'idée de ce que
nous faisons et nous sommes une organisation
qui couvre toute l'Europe
et qui stocke ensuite les patients, les
personnes décédées et qui souhaitent être
cryoconservées en Suisse, donc je vais
vous montrer comment tout cela fonctionne.
c'est notre ambulance basée à Berlin, bien
sûr, nous en avons également une à Amsterdam par l'
intermédiaire d'un partenaire et bientôt également une
en Suisse à Zurich,
donc toute la procédure
est pratiquement effectuée ici,
donc la logique fonctionne fondamentalement comme ça, n'est-ce
pas,
si le cœur de quelqu'un s'arrête à  à ce
stade, la dégradation cellulaire
commence essentiellement au niveau cellulaire, les
cellules commencent à s'auto-recycler pratiquement.
Maintenant, ce que vous voulez faire pour
arrêter ce processus, c'est d'abord vous voulez refroidir
et c'est la première étape qui est
effectuée
ici.  vous donnez une gamme de médicaments pour vous
assurer que le cerveau et le reste du
corps sont protégés contre tout type
de dégradation.
Dans ce cas, nous conduisons le corps en Suisse où le refroidissement se
fait à environ moins 196 degrés Celsius
et  à cette température, vous pouvez maintenant conserver
le corps que vous connaissez pendant quatre
décennies ou même des centaines d'années
sans aucune dégradation supplémentaire
jusqu'à un moment dans le futur où
tout ce processus pourra être inversé.
C'est l'idée fondamentale de ce que
nous faisons ici,
donc dans  cryopréservation, bien
sûr, la partie la plus importante qui doit
être préservée est le cerveau
et pour ce faire, vous devez perfuser, vous
devez apporter un agent cryoprotecteur
dans le corps, vous pouvez le faire directement
à travers les gros vaisseaux à côté du
cœur.  jeune artère, ce serait donc
ici la crosse aortique, comme
vous pouvez le voir ici,
laissez-moi comprendre,
donc vous introduisez essentiellement l'
agent protecteur du clairon directement à travers l'
ascendant ou l'eau, puis en raison de ce
type d'accès central à toutes les autres
artères de  du corps, l'
agent cryoprotecteur peut atteindre tous les
petits vaisseaux tous les plus gros vaisseaux et
tout cela est fondamentalement ce que nous faisons pour nous
assurer que la qualité d'une
conservation des criers est aussi élevée que
possible,
il est très important de toujours préciser
qu'actuellement nous  peut pleurer ou préserver les gens
mais nous ne pouvons pas les réveiller et pourtant nous ne pouvons pas
les sortir de la préservation du crime,
disons qu'il y a 50 ans, cette idée était
beaucoup plus proche de la science-fiction que
de la science aux États-Unis, ce
sujet existe depuis  beaucoup
plus longtemps qu'en Europe, donc depuis
presque 50 ans environ, c'est un
sujet aux États-Unis et même un sujet depuis
plus longtemps que cela, mais les organisations
existent depuis 50 ans,
merci,
bienvenue au 50e anniversaire de l'alcool, les
pingouins sont
venus ici.  je m'attendais en fait à 50
ou 80 personnes et nous nous retrouvons avec près de
200, ce qui, je pense, est probablement un record
pour nous,
alors ne laissez pas les gens se sentir à l'aise lorsque
vous parlez aux gens et qu'ils disent oh ouais
ouais, c'est bien, vous savez, la prolongation de la vie
est  tu vas venir me sauver,
euh, es-tu vraiment sûr de ça,
peut-être que tu devrais mettre ta ceinture de sécurité,
obtenir ton fonds d'urgence, mettre
en place tes systèmes chroniques et ensuite tu pourras te détendre
un peu, euh, il y a encore des choses que tu
peux faire pour t'améliorer.  vos chances, mais ensuite
vous avez les choses en place, vous pouvez
commencer à expérimenter ce genre de choses, mais
pour l'amour de Dieu, mettez le plan A en place
et pour beaucoup d'entre nous, planifier A, bien sûr,
signifie plan Alpha, merci
[Applaudissements]
bienvenue dans la vie Alcoa
Fondation d'extension ici à Scottsdale en Arizona aux
États-Unis, l'alcool existe depuis près de 50 ans,
euh, l'
organisation clionics la plus ancienne et ce que nous faisons
ici est essentiellement de donner aux gens une autre
chance dans la vie,
donc l'idée des chroniques est essentiellement
au point de mort légale, ce qui n'est pas le cas.
tout comme la mort biologique,
préservons la personne, empêchons-la de se
détériorer aussi parfaitement que possible,
puis emmenons-la dans le futur un
jour à la fois jusqu'à ce que nous disposions d'une
technologie plus avancée qui puisse réparer la
maladie cardiaque, son cancer et le
processus de vieillissement lui-même et permettre  qu'ils
continuent à vivre à nouveau dans
la salle d'opération de Local, bien qu'avant d'
arriver à ce stade, je veux expliquer
ce que nous faisons ici, nous allons retirer
autant de sang et de liquide intracellulaire que
possible du patient et le remplacer par
une solution cryoprotectrice maintenant
Cryoprotecteur que vous pouvez considérer simplement comme un
antigel de qualité médicale, mais environ la moitié de
nos membres, moi y compris, ont choisi
simplement de préserver le cerveau et vous pourriez
penser que c'est pourquoi voudriez-vous simplement
préserver le cerveau, n'avez-vous pas besoin d'un corps,
bien, vous le faites, mais  vous n'en avez pas besoin aujourd'hui
parce que mon point de vue est qu'au moment où j'en aurai
besoin, à moins que je sois tué tôt,
mon corps sera en assez mauvais
état dans quelques décennies, donc
tout devra être régénéré
de toute façon.  une chose que vous ne pouvez pas remplacer
est ici, c'est votre cerveau, nous pouvons
recommencer ici, mais ensuite nous allons
faire une séparation de quelques vertèbres plus bas, vous
voulez obtenir le haut de la moelle épinière
là-dedans, nous allons prendre  le
céphalon qui est ce que nous appelons le cerveau
plus le crâne,
nous allons le mettre à l'envers dans
l'anneau neurologique, le fixer dans cet
anneau, puis au lieu de passer
par les vaisseaux sanguins et le cœur,
nous allons plutôt  utilisez les
vaisseaux sanguins carotidiens ici, sinon c'est la
même procédure, ils vont circuler
à travers le système ici encore en
remplaçant le sang dans le cerveau et les
autres liquides par notre solution cryoprotectrice
ici dans notre cours de soins aux patients Bay, nous
avons les 185 patients humains et environ
88 animaux, allons y jeter un oeil
[Applaudissements]
donc ces vaisseaux que vous voyez sont ceux qui
contiennent nos patients, ils sont appelés
des faiseurs d-e-w-a-r, ce sont des faiseurs cryogéniques,
ils ressemblent beaucoup à une bouteille thermos
si vous avez déjà utilisé une bouteille thermos pour
garder votre  café chaud ou boisson froide, vous
savez comment ça marche, ils ont une
couche de vide à l'intérieur donc ici je peux mettre ma
tête dessus, c'est juste une sorte de chili métallique
mais à l'intérieur il fait extrêmement froid, il fait moins
320 degrés Fahrenheit ou moins 196 degrés
Celsius donc très très froid  qui est un
modèle contenant quatre
patients au corps entier, donc il y a un patient dans chacun
de ces modules qui est juste pour la
protection mécanique, donc s'il y a une raison pour laquelle
ils se coincent, ils sont protégés
et nous utilisons ces crochets pour avoir un
treuil dans le  toit là-bas, nous le soulevons simplement
et les posons ici pour qu'ils
soient avec trois autres personnes, nous avons donc
quatre patients du corps entier et nous pouvons en
fait avoir dans la colonne centrale plusieurs
patients neurologiques ou nous pouvons avoir des animaux de compagnie en
haut  colonne donc quatre
patients du corps entier et cinq patients neuronaux ou nous
pouvons convertir un de ces conteneurs pour
stocker réellement des patients de 10 euros en
plaçant des étagères ici afin que vous puissiez
potentiellement obtenir 45 neuropations dans l'un
d'entre eux, c'est donc ce
que nous avons utilisé pour un  depuis longtemps,
mais maintenant nous avons un nouveau modèle qui est
celui-ci, le superduer, donc maintenant nous pouvons accueillir
environ 11 patients du corps entier dans le
même espace au sol, vous savez donc que cela représente
entre la moitié et le tiers du coût
par azote liquide pour l'espace de location et
ainsi de suite, cela a vraiment aidé à maintenir
cela sur les coûts à long terme,
surtout si vous êtes un membre à part entière,
une bonne partie de l'argent que vous payez
pour cela sur le minimum de deux cent mille
dollars que nous avons mis de côté pour
longtemps-  stockage à terme donc comme nous avons fait toutes
les procédures tous les transports la
protection l'opération chirurgicale après tout il nous
reste plus de la moitié de l'argent
placé dans un fonds fiduciaire spécial protégé
qui ne peut être utilisé à aucune autre fin
et qui maintient  les gens dans ces quatre
aussi longtemps qu'il le faudra et euh vous savez, comme
vous l'avez mentionné, la personne que nous avons le
plus longtemps était présente dans la chorale en 1967 et nous
l'avons toujours donc nous n'avons pas encore perdu le
patient
[Musique]
alors j'ai eu ce
look de sac  au logo incroyable, je veux dire, c'est cool,
je ne sais pas ce qu'il y a dedans, il y a
quelques cadeaux, je suppose que j'espère qu'il y a un
petit cerveau jouet que je pourrai mettre sur mon
étagère
[Rires]
mon cerveau sera dans l'un de ces faiseurs
ma tête sera sur un support à l'intérieur de l'un de
ces acteurs, donc c'est amusant, c'est
presque plus amusant que d'avoir
un petit cerveau jouet.
Je suis raisonnablement convaincu que la
conscience et l'identité seraient
réservées si le cerveau est constitué d'
organismes biologiques qui  ce qui compte, ce sont
les souvenirs,
peu importe, c'est la personnalité
qui compte, je pense qu'une
fois que nous nous retrouverons réellement dans le
futur, dans cet avenir technologique, avec
toutes ces options qui nous sont proposées, téléchargez
ou non si je représente ou ou ce
genre de  le téléchargement ou ce genre de
téléchargement en ligne avec toutes ces
technologies, le mouvement de la mort est simplement
de plusieurs manières,
donc étant donné que le cerveau est un
système dynamique et qu'il s'agit ensuite d'
un milliard d'attracteurs et de pièces mobiles,
je n'entends jamais les gens parler de cela,
mais quand  nous sommes gelés, évidemment, nous sommes
gelés dans un état dans quelle mesure êtes-
vous sûr que le gel d'un système dynamique se
souviendra de la manière dont vous pourriez
perdre la structure, je pense qu'au
moins vous perdriez certainement comme ce que
vous pensiez à ce moment-là.  Je suis
désespéré d'avoir l'idée que cela
va réellement correspondre à mon état
de pensée et d'expérience actuel,
mais je pense que vous pourriez soulever cette
inquiétude selon laquelle, d'une manière ou d'une autre, ce n'est pas seulement mon état de pensée et d'
expérience actuel
à tout moment au cours des dernières années dans lesquelles mon
cerveau se trouve.  une certaine trajectoire et
peut-être que cette trajectoire dynamique fait partie de ce qui me fait que
pensez-vous que
vous serez téléchargé,
autoriseriez-vous que les neurones de votre cerveau
soient remplacés par des puces de silicium
qui tirent mieux,
elles vous rendent plus intelligent
non, vous voulez votre cerveau d'origine
Connaissez-vous l'idée de vous téléporter donc nous
allons détruire votre corps ici mais nous allons en
créer une nouvelle version comme euh
à Las Cruces, c'est un peu comme l'
impression 3D si vous tombez sur ça oui
vous imprimez, c'est comme un  Imprimez une copie
de vous en 3D oui
Imprimez une copie de vous en 3D à Las
Cruces,
économisez les 500
si vous savez que ce n'est peut-être pas vraiment vous,
ce sera juste un nouveau vous qui pense
qu'il est exactement vous ouais
vous êtes inquiet  que tu pourrais mourir
Je ne veux pas renaître dans le futur
et ne pas rester ni être en vie c'est juste
cool, tellement nouveau ou comme s'ils étaient toujours
exactement la même personne comme si tout était
pareil sauf que ce n'est pas moi qui
fais réellement les choses  En voyant les choses, c'est quelqu'un
d'autre donc je suis toujours mort,
dis-moi quand tu auras fini, j'allumerai
les lumières,
d'accord, tous ceux qui ont plus de photos,
es-tu prêt, d'accord, euh, le
super faiseur, tu vois Ray à l'
arrière, là-bas, qui est en forme.  différemment
des autres et nous avons des commandes pour, euh,
je pense que pour un Super faiseur supplémentaire
en commande, il faut environ six
mois pour fabriquer une de ces choses. Je
sais que c'est étrange qu'Alcor soit situé
dans le désert mais ils l'ont fait pour
plusieurs raisons.  L'Arizona est très
stable géologiquement, nous n'avons pas de
tremblements de terre, nous n'avons pas non plus d'ouragans
ou de tornades et une autre raison est que nous
avons sept fabricants d'azote liquide
dans la vallée. L'azote liquide est
en fait un produit très bon marché, il coûte 19
cents le litre, c'est un sous-produit de
un autre processus qui nous permet, euh,
vous savez, c'est la raison pour laquelle nous les avons
immergés dans de l'azote liquide et qui est
maintenu à la température
Ellis, nous devrions vous faire inscrire à
Alcor parce qu'ils le changent en
fonction de l'âge, donc si vous  Je peux me bloquer
à un taux de neuf ans.
Je veux dire,
c'est un compromis parce que tu
paieras bien tout ce que nous avons passé depuis plus d'années,
mais ce sera un taux moins cher,
donc
ou du moins, nous devrions demander à ton père de le faire.
inscrivez-vous,
cela dépendra peut-être de Mère Nature lorsque nous
mourrons,
mais comme nous sommes une partie sensible et
consciente de la nature,
je ne vois aucune raison de ne pas participer activement
à influencer cette décision, une
personne ne peut pas faire grand-chose compte tenu de sa
durée de vie limitée, imaginez  vivre 80
années vigoureuses ou plus avant que les
effets de l'âge ne vous envahissent de sorte que
vos années de jeunesse se prolongent considérablement
des fois,
une durée de vie plus longue bénéficierait à la société
dans son ensemble,
nous serions plus sages en tant qu'espèce, je crois
qu'en moyenne, nous devenons plus sages avec l'âge,
lorsque les gens vivent jusqu'à un âge très mûr, ils ont
vu l'histoire se répéter avec les
mêmes résultats
qu'ils ont eu beaucoup  de temps pour revoir
leur passé
et acquérir une compréhension plus claire de ce
qui est vraiment important dans la vie.
J'aimerais pouvoir zapper à temps
et voir ce qui pourrait devenir de nous
Alice
étrangère.
Je pense que c'est un peu de là que vient une grande partie de mon
câblage cérébral.  du point de vue de mon
intérêt pour
les mathématiques et les sciences, puis lorsque j'ai
obtenu mon diplôme à Berkeley, maman et papa
m'ont donné un ordinateur Apple 2ci et la seule
chose que nous pouvions vraiment faire sur Internet
parce qu'il n'y avait pas encore de World Wide Web
était de suivre les informations.  groupes mais les seuls qui
m'intéressaient étrangement à ma grande
surprise avaient quelque chose à voir avec la physique
euh pas tellement les maths parce que je ne
comprenais pas les maths mais tout ce qui avait à voir avec la
technologie le futurisme le
transhumanisme même la cryonie qui
glace les humains
et
à l'époque je  en fait, c'était comme si j'avais eu
cette Grande Epiphanie d'un seul coup et
je pensais que
la raison pour laquelle nous devions nous geler
était que si nous allions dans l'espace lointain et que nous devions
atteindre la prochaine étoile, nous devions
soit faire passer des générations.  au
moment où nous y arrivons ou apprenons à geler les
humains, j'ai en quelque sorte essayé d'inculquer
la même excitation du câblage cérébral
à mes
espèces filles qui deviennent pleinement conscientes d'elles-mêmes au
point qu'elles peuvent réfléchir à leur
conscience de soi lorsque la nôtre devient pleinement
concentrée.  lorsque cette caméra s'est retournée
complètement et s'est pointée exactement vers
nous-mêmes, créant cette
boucle de rétroaction verrouillée, nous traversons une étape gênante et
troublante de notre histoire, nous devons
faire de petits pas pour nous adapter à la nature comme le
faisait notre ancien moi, mais maintenant en tant que
mental  mais maintenant, ce sont
des créatures mentalement ailées, nous le faisons avec un sentiment
de facteur plus important, une
compréhension profonde du monde naturel,
y compris l'émotion de la théorie du chaos,
la première question est vraiment que nous pensons que
nous avons une
durée de vie naturelle,
vous savez, ils l'appellent la limite haineuse
et  c'est parce que les télomères qui sont
les coiffes de ces chromosomes deviennent
de plus en plus courts et
laissent l'ADN vulnérable
et ce que vous avez découvert, c'est qu'il s'agit d'
un processus réversible
ouais, ce qui est vraiment intéressant, c'est que vous
ne parlez pas de vivre éternellement, vous êtes  je
parle vraiment d'
atteindre une vieillesse en bonne santé,
sans maladies de la
vieillesse, aussi tard que possible.
[Musique]
mélanger
donc je m'appelle Linda Partridge et nous sommes à l'
Institut Max Planck pour la biologie du
vieillissement en  Cologne et nous nous intéressons
aux interventions particulièrement nutritionnelles,
mais aussi aux systèmes moléculaires du
corps qui détectent les aliments et à la manière
dont ils affectent le processus de vieillissement et les
maladies liées au vieillissement. Nous effectuons également des
travaux expérimentaux et nous sommes dans l'un des
laboratoires expérimentaux de  le
moment avec les mouches, les mouches des fruits, la drosophile
et les souris du
point de vue évolutif, le
vieillissement est vraiment étrange, car à mesure qu'un
organisme ou une personne vieillit, il devient
plus susceptible de mourir, donc le vieillissement individuel
est une mauvaise chose inconditionnelle, mais si
vous regardez la nature, vous  J'ai des choses
qui peuvent vivre 200 ans pour la baleine boréale
ou 40 ans pour les chauves-souris et d'autres choses qui ne
vivent qu'un jour. C'est un trait qui
existe dans la nature et qui évolue, mais
c'est un désavantage individuel, alors comment
cela peut-il arriver, bien sûr.  beaucoup
de spéculations sur le vieillissement des personnes sont
bien sûr intéressées à essayer de rester en
bonne santé en vieillissant et même dans certains
cas à essayer d'éviter complètement la mort,
donc je pense que les idées que nous allons, vous
savez, seront capables de préserver les gens ou vous
savez  téléchargez ce logiciel et
recréez-les à l'avenir.
Je veux dire, ce sont de grandes choses pour la
science-fiction en ce moment mais c'est de
la fiction. Je pense que nous ne voyons pas dans
les résultats de la recherche expérimentale
pour le moment grand signe que cela
va se produire dans  Dans un avenir prévisible, il y a
eu des
recherches récentes vraiment intéressantes aux États-Unis
qui, je pense, sont
très prometteuses et pourraient être
transposables à l'homme. Les
expériences initiales étaient donc légèrement Frankenstein.
Les expérimentateurs ont pris des
souris et des souris généralement issues de
souches consanguines afin que vous puissiez réellement  réunir
leurs réserves de sang mais les
réunir sans qu'il y ait de problème de
réaction contre le
sang de l'autre souris car elles sont toutes
génétiquement identiques les unes aux autres
et les expérimentateurs ont donc voulu poser
la question s'ils avaient donné du
sang jeune à une vieille souris
cela peut-il améliorer sa santé au cours du vieillissement,
alors ils ont fait les expériences contrôlées évidentes,
ils ont attaché une vieille souris
à une vieille souris, une jeune souris à une jeune
souris, mais ils ont ensuite fait le contraire d'une vieille souris
à une jeune souris, ils ont montré une amélioration de la
santé des cellules souches.  donc ce que cela
nous dit, c'est que soit les mauvaises choses
s'accumulent dans le sang au cours du vieillissement, de sorte que
l'ancienne circulation contient
des molécules nocives ou d'autres facteurs, soit il y a
des choses particulièrement bénéfiques dans le
sang jeune, mais dans tous les cas, si elles peuvent
être identifiées, car le sang est un élément très
accessible.  chose, il devrait être possible
d'éliminer les facteurs dommageables chez les
personnes âgées ou d'ajouter des facteurs de rajeunissement chez les jeunes. Il
y a donc beaucoup d'intérêt bien sûr
maintenant à identifier les molécules et à
comprendre comment elles agissent sur
différents types de cellules souches pour améliorer
leurs performances au cours du vieillissement.  de
nombreux murs sont construits dans le domaine scientifique,
parfois il y a un grand pas en avant et une nouvelle
découverte, mais souvent, cela comble
les vides d'un très grand mur de
découvertes. Les
médias étrangers se sont moqués du
lien
entre ces événements météorologiques extrêmes et le
changement climatique.
donc pour ceux qui sont encore sceptiques
quant aux effets du climat
[Musique]
Jessica
de la science,
comment va ta citrouille, chérie, bon
oh
effrayant,
je suis tellement excitée d'avoir trouvé cette
citrouille de vaisseau spatial extraterrestre ouais parce que je suis
sûr que les gens les élèvent pour avoir l'air  J'aime
ça
pour ressembler à des vaisseaux spatiaux extraterrestres.
J'ai juste besoin de mettre des lumières autour.
Je ne sais pas si le bleu semble correct mais
nous verrons
donc j'ai l'impression qu'à l'avenir, nous
penserons davantage
au type d'extraterrestres qui sont  en
faisant des choses, nous allons leur ressembler
parce que si nous sommes en apesanteur, nous
aurons moins de densité osseuse, nous
ressemblerions probablement à une espèce complètement différente
parce qu'il y a moins de gravité,
donc ils pourraient être plus grands et plus maigres,
ils ne le feront pas  ils ont besoin d'
os solides
mais quand ils arriveront ici, ils seront
dans un fauteuil roulant
ouais probablement
ouais c'est comme un autre type d'
évolution où ça arrive tout d'un
coup tu vas sur Mars la prochaine très prochaine
génération les enfants sont comme
super grands comme  haricots verts oh mon
Dieu,
je ne voudrais pas être aussi grand pour être
honnête, c'est un peu comme si on construisait d'abord
une maison,
cette maison a déjà beaucoup de briques dont
nous aurions besoin de deux fois plus si nous
étions si grands
ouais je  techniquement, pour les autres extraterrestres,
nous sommes en quelque sorte des extraterrestres, eh
bien, c'est vrai, d'accord,
prêt trois deux un fromage,
euhmacaroni,
je veux dire, si nous disons fromage, pourquoi ne pas simplement
dire macaroni au fromage,
merci, d'accord, les gars, merci,
je n'aime tout simplement pas le  l'idée de mourir
ce n'est pas que j'ai peur de mourir je veux dire
peut-être que je le ferais je
ne sais pas je n'y pense pas comme ça j'ai
peur j'y pense car je n'aime tout simplement
pas l'idée que les choses se
passent  pour finir, ce n'est pas que
je veux dire que
je suis motivé
en partie parce que je sais que je vais au
moins, je veux dire, très probablement périr à un
moment donné, mais dans mon esprit, bien sûr, j'y
pense pendant que je suis en pause,
euh, comme  Max Moore dit que j'aurai
besoin d'aide et que je veux être préservé,
donc je traverse la vie avec cet état d'esprit,
alors laissez-moi réfléchir, laissez-moi essayer de penser à ce que ce
serait si je pensais encore vraiment que la
mort était ça
et qu'il y avait  rien d'autre, aucune
possibilité
ouais c'est déprimant, je trouve juste ça
déprimant et j'ai l'impression que même s'il est
impossible d'être immortel d'une manière ou d'une autre et tout
d'abord Immortel ne veut pas dire
indestructible, même les méduses seraient
écrasées, elles ne sont plus immortelles
donc ça veut juste dire euh  qu'ils ne
mourront pas du vieillissement,
j'ai l'impression que même s'il est impossible de
rendre les gens immortels, pourquoi ne pas
s'efforcer d'y parvenir et s'efforcer d'avoir une
durée de vie plus longue
et bien sûr, il y a ce genre de
mentalité selon laquelle si vous pouvez vivre le plus longtemps
possible,
alors  j'espère qu'à un moment donné avant de
mourir, quelqu'un découvrira une meilleure
façon de vivre encore plus longtemps
et alors Alcor deviendra le plan B
mais
je suppose que je retournerais simplement la
question et dirais pourquoi
quelqu'un serait-il plus heureux à l'idée de
mourir  que l'idée de ne pas mourir et
personnellement, je ne peux pas comprendre que
je ne peux pas imaginer
être simplement à l'aise avec l'idée
de mourir et c'est tout ce que je
ne peux pas imaginer
merci.
Je m'appelle Judith Campisi et je suis ici au
Buck Institute.  en Californie du Nord
et cet institut est l'ensemble de l'
institut qui travaille sur le vieillissement, nous travaillons sur
les maladies du vieillissement mais aussi sur les processus de base
qui semblent être importants pour le
vieillissement, donc il y a beaucoup de réclamations
généralement de la part d'entreprises qui prétendent que si vous
faites ceci ou cela, vous  Je vais
vivre longtemps
et
cela peut durer 500 ans ou
des milliers d'années. Je veux dire, certains
clients sont tout simplement indignés. Il n'y a absolument
aucune preuve que nous ne pouvons même pas
faire vivre une souris cinq ans au lieu
de trois ans.  et encore moins un humain pour vivre
des centaines d'années,
personne n'a trouvé de moyen de prendre une
espèce complexe comme une souris ou un humain
et de la faire vivre beaucoup
plus longtemps, cela peut être fait avec
des organismes simples comme les petits vers que vous voyez
Alex mais  cela ne peut vraiment pas être fait dans
des organismes compliqués comme les souris ou les
humains, donc Hayflick a été le premier à
décrire ce processus appelé sénescence cellulaire
et il a établi que
les cellules humaines normales ne se divisent pas indéfiniment et
lorsqu'elles s'arrêtent, elles
sont fondamentalement irréversiblement empêchées de
proliférer à nouveau, donc  il pensait que cela
pourrait avoir quelque chose à voir avec le vieillissement, vous
savez, si vous vous coupez, vous ne
guérissez pas aussi vite, c'est parce que les cellules ne se
divisent pas aussi rapidement lorsque nous fabriquons une
souris où nous pouvons nous débarrasser de ces
cellules et de cette bouche.  a une durée
de vie moyenne qui est considérablement plus longue,
mais la durée de vie maximale de cette
souris est toujours la même, la bouche meurt toujours
et elle meurt à peu
près dans les délais,
donc de quoi meurt-elle, il
s'avère qu'elle meurt de beaucoup de choses
dont les souris meurent normalement, mais  tout est
compressé pour qu'ils ne passent pas les
six derniers mois de leur vie malades,
mais juste quelques semaines, puis ils meurent
et je pense que l'un des
objectifs réalistes de la recherche moderne sur le vieillissement
est d'améliorer la santé
au point où  tu vas mourir c'est sûr
mais tu meurs
comme je l'ai dit sur ce court de tennis et
tu gagnes et puis boum tu as 110
ans et tu es mort
étranger
[Musique]
J'ai 86 ans
donc ça ouvre la question est-ce
que je veux  vivre
Je ne veux probablement pas vivre encore 100 ans
en étant
aussi impuissant que je le suis
si je devais
rejoindre une
foule chronique
dans mon état actuel
Je ne serais pas heureux parce que mon cerveau
ne fonctionne pas très bien
Je ne suis plus la même personne que moi  Avant,
j'aimerais voir l'avenir,
mais qu'as-tu dû abandonner pour
cela, c'est la
curiosité qui
serait le moteur qui me donnerait
envie de rester là pour
toujours,
voici le futur,
viens,
hé grand-mère
bonjour,
je t'aime, je t'aime
étranger
[Musique] la
mélodie étrangère
est
faite en combinaison biologique
ou abaisse le cancer bien sûr
seul
sampler
[Musique]
la première
un exemple
il euh euh
la lune optimisme
métabolisme étranger
génétique femmes
ou maximum
principal de la Sue Francis
Telma
étranger
[Musique]
euh
comment savez-vous que vous n'êtes pas dans la Matrice,
vous ne vivez pas dans cette simulation informatique géante,
comment connaissez-vous le
monde extérieur, alors bien sûr, la
question se pose, comment savons-nous que nous ne sommes pas
dans l'un de ceux-là, je suppose  sérieusement,
la possibilité que le monde dans lequel nous vivons
soit en fait une simulation, la
technologie de simulation s'améliore tout le
temps, en fait, il existe deux
types différents de simulation.
Des technologies
étrangères,
ne serait-ce pas bizarre si
vous faisiez aussi ce
que j'espère que vous faites,
mais  Je te laisse attendre jusqu'à ce que tu aies 18 ans et
tu comprendras, et s'ils
nous ressuscitaient tous en même temps,
est-ce que ce serait cool ou serait-ce
super grinçant, je ne sais pas,
d'accord, alors voici le truc sur lequel les plantes  La Terre
survit parce qu'elle est habituée au cycle jour-nuit de 24 heures.
Mars est la même chose que
la Terre, c'est juste plus 40 minutes supplémentaires,
oh oui, les gens devraient le remarquer
principalement parce que pas principalement parce que nous
aurions plus de temps pour paresser
le matin, mais surtout  parce que les
plantes pousseraient et parce que nous y serions
plus habitués,
ouais, nous y serions plus habitués parce que je suis
presque sûr de la manière dont nous sommes
descendus, je suis presque sûr que nos cerveaux sont
automatiquement un peu comme  pas comme combien de
temps dormir pas exactement mais comme un peu
quand
et une estimation pas une estimation mais comme
un peu autour tu sais ça sait en quelque sorte
aller au sommet de la colline ouais
enfin la lune s'est levée
enfin
oh nous pouvons Hurler à la Lune
[Musique]
c'est vraiment beau,
chérie, je pense qu'il est temps
de dormir un peu pour l'école la
semaine dernière à l'
étranger
[Musique]
Je suis professeur d'anatomie à l'
Université de Californie à San
Francisco, c'est une
belle journée ici dans une forêt de séquoias
en Californie du Nord, il
s'agit d'une forêt de séquoias de seconde génération.
La croyance selon laquelle ils sont vieux de plusieurs siècles
ou millénaires est en fait un mythe
si vous affirmez que les arbres se
trouvent au même endroit depuis autant d'
années, ce qui est exact, mais le plus ancien
vivant  les cellules d'un séquoia ou d'un
pin Bristlecone qui sont tout aussi vieux ou
même des
cellules vivantes plus âgées n'ont pas plus de 30
ans on les trouve dans les poils absorbants
ou dans les aiguilles
de sorte que l'
âge de ces vieux arbres est l'âge des
morts  tissu,
il est illogique de prétendre que les arbres
sont les êtres vivants les plus anciens si la
partie vivante de l'arbre n'a
en réalité
pas plus de 33 à 35 ans, comme cela a été déterminé,
car nous avons également des idées fausses sur l'âge
des séquoias.
idées fausses sur
notre biologie en ce qui concerne le
vieillissement.
L'idée fausse
est l'incapacité à faire la distinction entre
le processus de vieillissement qui est un
processus destructeur ou un processus dans lequel la fonction est
perdue, par opposition à la
détermination de la longévité qui est un processus qui
vous maintient en vie.
Par exemple, vous pouvez  continuez à vivre
plus longtemps si vous faites attention aux
règles de bon sens que nous connaissons tous
en ce qui concerne
l'exercice, le maintien de votre santé
et une alimentation appropriée, tous ces
mécanismes, ces moyens de survie
ont pour résultat final d'
augmenter votre longévité
sous-jacente à ce système.  ou phénomène est
le phénomène du vieillissement qui est un
processus qui a ses origines dans
les molécules ou les atomes même
et ce processus est régi non pas par les
lois biologiques mais par les lois de la physique
et les lois physiques. Cette loi
applicable est la deuxième loi de la
thermodynamique qui  est que l'énergie a tendance
à se dissiper ou à se propager à partir d'une source
et que la source d'énergie et les
molécules biologiques sont pour la plupart les
liaisons chimiques qui maintiennent ces
molécules complexes ensemble.
Ces liaisons s'affaiblissent avec le temps
et la molécule devient dysfonctionnelle,
de sorte que le processus de vieillissement s'ensuit.  commence
la préoccupation majeure de beaucoup de gens dans
ce domaine,
c'est l'incapacité à faire la distinction entre
ces deux processus
et aussi la croyance
qu'ils peuvent surmonter une loi physique
en
apprenant à éliminer le
processus de vieillissement qui ne peut pas être fait, c'est
une loi.  de la physique, c'est juste qu'une loi
ouais, je ne sais pas si vous êtes
intéressé par les histoires drôles mais si
vous êtes intéressé, dites-en une qui a à voir
avec la façon dont on peut
distinguer
euh la
démence pré-sénile
et la démence sénile  la
démence pré-sénile,
c'est quand
un homme quitte les toilettes et
oublie de fermer sa fermeture éclair.
la perte de mémoire à court terme
et euh
je ne me souviens pas des deux autres
étrangers
[Musique] [
Musique]
[Musique]